hello and welcome to pi data global my
name is kevin i am very very happy to be
here and to be your host for this
session so now uh i would like to
welcome emily
to our session uh she will talk about is
my data drifting
early monitoring for machine learning
models in production really interesting
topic
so
emily is the co-founder and cto at
event
evidently ai sorry yeah a startup
a startup developing open source tools
to analyze and monitor the performance
of machine learning models so i will
pass it to you emily welcome
hi there thank you so much for a nice
introduction
i'm happy to be here today and welcome
everybody who joined today i'm going to
tackle a question is my data just and
how i can use the day-to-day detection
as an early monitoring for machine
learning models
my name is emily i'm cto and co-founder
of evidently and evidently we build an
open source tools to analyze and
validate machine learning models
so everybody knows that it's quite hard
to build machine learning model by
itself we need to access a lot of data
sources create a data set run a bunch of
experiments and then build the
production servers and deploy it
well even if you do this the work
doesn't stop because the model is
already in production it generates some
business value and each year costs
something so we need to make sure that
our models works exactly as they
expected so what can go wrong with the
machine learning model since we moved in
production
well there are a lot of issues that can
happen
there can be some data processing issue
for example broken pipelines or some
infrastructure updates
or it can be data schema change for
example if you use some third-party api
and the api hosts do some changes like
rename couple of columns or move it
around it can seem very harmless for
them but our model will suffer
often the data can be lost even at the
source for example it can be broken
physical sensors or
the login can be implemented with the
errors
if you have more complicated
infrastructure for example we are using
a bunch of machine learning models and
they are in connected
well if the first model which output we
use as the input for the rest models is
working wrong then all the rest models
will suffer so there are a lot of
technical things that can happen with
our data
but let's say we fix all these issues
and our data engineering team made their
job done
even in this case there are some things
that we should worry about and this is
the environment
well since we move machine learning
models in production they start to
interact with the real world and this
world is not the constant things tends
to change
let's assume that we have a term
prediction model the trend to predict
whether each individual user is going to
churn
we could have some marketing campaign
that attracts new users and if recently
after super successful marketing
campaign we recently bought a lot of
users from social networks our model can
start work worse just because it hasn't
seen such users before during the
training procedure
in this case we need to collect more
data about such users in order to
demonstrate it to the model and let
model learn
their patterns and this is the example
of data trees
together with this data gift we can face
the model's output gist which can be
output drift or target drift
well this target rift can be continuous
where small changes accumulate over the
time and change the target function that
we are trying to estimate or it can be
sudden and the recent pandemic is the
perfect example of such
concentris
almost overnight a lot of patterns has
changed and many machine learning models
become irrelevant
well now we know that there are many
things that can happen with the models
it can be related to input data or to
the changes in the environment well how
to prepare to it
obviously we need to set up a monitoring
and one can say we have the production
services for ages why can't we just
reuse the existing monitoring schema to
the machine learning based services
well we definitely can do it and we
should because in the first place we're
talking about production services so we
need to meet our service health we need
to worry about uptime memory usage
latency and things things like that
but together with the service house we
need to worry about data health and
model health because there are a lot of
issues related to the data and model so
let's discuss how can we do that
when we're talking about machine
learning service monitoring we mostly
start from the model performance well
it's logical enough because the
performance is the things we uh worry
about in the first place and there are
two basically basical approach we can
use so we can either focus on model
quality or year and for example for
classification models you can calculate
metrics like precision recall or
algorithmic loss
if we have a regression model we can
calculate mean absolute year or mean
absolute percentage here there are a lot
of standard metrics that tells us
how good our model is in terms of
quality
another approach is to focus more on
business or product metrics because we
are talking about the production usage
of machine learning model and it means
that you have some production service so
if you sell something you can focus on
purchases if you have a media platform
you can calculate things like clicks
views and etc
in most cases this is enough because it
tells us directly what is happening with
our model and shows us whether it works
exactly as we expected or not
but often it's just not enough
sometimes you have very specific cases
where we cannot
lay on the performance
for example if we have some service
which helps us to predict the demand for
our products we can build this
prediction with a solid horizon for
example we can predict the demand
for a month or several months even half
of the year in advance right and in
these cases to directly calculate the
model's quality mainly here we need to
get this feedback or ground rules and
only after that we can measure the
quality
well sometimes it's too late because if
our models start degrading quality we
will just miss this moment and for quite
a long period of time our model will
work worse than we expected
another case is where we have the target
function which is really volatile
in this case as the target is volatile
itself the error can be also volatile
and you can just miss the moment when
models started work worse just because
we will think that it's another
um switching in the quality of the model
right that it's just the shake of the
model and this can be a problem
third case is when our model operates on
top of the
bunch of objects from different segments
for example different segments of users
or different categories of products
in this case you easily can have
different quality for different segments
and one can say okay but we can just
measure quality by segments right and
analyze them separately
well it's possible if i have let's say
two or three or maybe five segments but
if you have really a lot it's became a
problem sometimes they are
overcompensated one another when we tend
to underestimate for example the demand
on top of one segment and underestimate
the demand on top of another they just
compensate just one another and it's
hard to measure it directly
it became even more complicated when the
sizes of such segments changing and we
really can't figure out what is
happening
last but not least example is when we
have a delay but this delay is small not
months or half of the year and in this
case you can assume well
let's calculate the quality like euro or
precision and assume that if the quality
is well enough now that in future it
will be also good
this is nice assumption but there is no
guarantee unfortunately and if we have a
delay for a day or maybe a couple of
hours then we can just miss the moment
when model's quality starts decreasing
sometimes it's okay but sometimes it
costs really a lot and for these cases
we need to come up with some better
solutions
what can it be
the earlier monitoring is the perfect
idea there
we can analyze the data that are already
enhanced and try to make conclusions on
top of this available data and this is
input features and models output
what can you calculate on top of the
existing data data drift of course
because this is the shift into on top of
the input data distributions a model's
output is already enhanced so we can
check if the model's output distribution
has changed and outlier detection of
course because we can detect outlier on
top of the input features well let's
discuss it in more details
let's start from the data drift so data
gift this is the case where the
distributions of our data is shifting
first of all i need to say that data
drift is not always the problem right
because if you build a model on top of
let's say equally important features and
only small shares of such features is
drifting sometimes our models are robust
enough to survive it
but if you have super important features
and they are different this can be
signal often early problems
right so
here it's important to
decide on the monitoring schema
carefully we need to figure out which
exact statistical tests we use because
the influence on the results right
we need to choose the reasonable
confidence level for our statistical
tests it can be 80
it can be 99
we should decide
and of course alert conditions are super
important because we do not know to get
a lot of wrong alerts but we still do
not want to miss something
and the question is how to make sure
that the monitoring schema that you
choose is well enough and for doing this
i suggest to use historical data
you can check whether is the created
mentoring schema you cover all the
important things from your past and you
do not send too much wrong false alarms
and you can do it on top of historical
data so this is the good idea to make
sure that your monitoring schema is good
enough
in most cases we use non-parametric
statistical tests to detect data gift
and this is logical enough well
non-parametric statistics doesn't
require too much
assumption for our input data right we
do not know we don't need to have the
normally distributed data and we can
just use non-parametric tests for most
of our input features but it's not for
free
and evidently we believe that it's
important to use both parametric and
non-parametric tests
in many cases for our input features we
can assume that some of them have normal
distribution right and even more for
some of our features we can assume some
parameters of this distribution for
example we can expect that some features
have normal distribution with specific
means and in this case you can use one
sample z test or one sample t test to
analyze this mean and compare whether
our current data have these specific
distributions and same idea works for
one proportion that tests if we are
talking about binary categorical data
if you cannot come up with such
assumption from the very beginning we
can use our reference dataset already if
you have one
we can take the data set from the
training and it can serve us as a
reference
so here if we can still assume that some
features have normal distribution we can
compare the means or the proportions for
categorical data of course
if it's binary between the reference
data set and the current data set for
example we can compare two normally
distributed features from recent and
from the reference data and check if
these distributions have equal means
such tests have a
pretty nice power and they can help us
detect drift earlier
for all the rest features of course we
should continue using non-parametric
tests but not limit ourselves to
kolmogorov's nernov test for numerical
features and pearson's g squared test
for categorical ones
there are more very nice statistical
tests like for example case sample
anderson darling which have which is
more powerful compared to common gross
minor often and
sometimes you need to account for a
smaller data set for example let's say
you have machine learning models which
you apply pretty rare for example once a
day or even once a week in this case you
probably will have smaller data set and
exact tests will work well there for
example fishers or bernards well
it's a lot right
and evidently we previewed the very nice
dashboards and reports that can help you
to figure out whether your data is
drifting we already implemented many
different statistical tests and
implementing more so just you can
automatically use this prebuilt
dashboard and see what is happening with
your features
there is no need to select the specific
tests we will do it automatically the
only thing you sometimes need is to
figure out the type of your data because
well often to build machine learning
models we encode categorical data with
digits and if we will parse this
automatically we might think that this
is the numerical feature and started to
apply the
magor smirnoff or some test for
numerical features in this case it's
better to provide the making to
help us detect the type of the feature
correctly
together with data gist we have a report
to analyze model's output drift and the
target drift if you already have a
target so both for regression or
classification it can help to figure out
whether the model's output or target is
drifting
so well let's say you have this
information enhanced and we know whether
our data and prediction is drifting
so
what does it mean how to interpret it
and well
as most machine learning problems it
depends on the context right it can be
negative or positive
for example if your data drift detected
but prediction prediction drift is not
detected it can be a negative because
well if your important features has
changed model probably should have
reacted
but it didn't
in this case we can conclude that our
model does not extrapolate that well and
probably we need to enter and intervene
really soon and do something
positive scenario is also
possible
let's assume our important features did
not change and our model is robust
enough to survive drift well in this
case there is no need to intervene and
we can continue using the existing model
let's move to the second case in second
case we could have data drift detected
together with prediction drift
the positive interpretation is that our
importer important feature features has
changed and our model's output is also
changed
well if the changes are exactly as we
expected for example the prices for some
products get slower and our model
predicts the higher demand is this
logical enough then you can say that our
model extrapolates well enough and we
can continue using this model this is
the grade
maybe if the changes continue
accumulates later we will need calibrate
or even retrain or rebuild the model but
at the moment we can continue using it
the negative scenario is that our
important features has changed models
behavior elsa has changed but not in a
logical way so we cannot really rely on
the model's output and probably this is
the signal that we will see the
increasing error really soon in this
case we need to enter in immediately and
update our model or maybe switch
the process to some rule based system or
manual review
together with the data drift we can use
the outlier detection
well outlier detection schema will help
us to catch bugs and higher errors even
before we can detect some changes in the
distributions
because well to calculate
the statistical tests which compares to
distribution we need to first accumulate
enough data to actually detect these 10
changes
confidently enough
sometimes if each individual year costs
something it makes sense to monitor the
outliers together with the data list
there is one additional way how we can
use the statistics we can calculate the
share of drifting objects and use this
this information as an
alternative schema of drift detection
right because well if we have a lot of
new outliers coming to our system
probably the data is changing and we can
detect it earlier
well this is a very nice approach to use
when the cost of each individual
individual euro is high
well let's say we detected drift and we
have all the information it has
the next super important question is how
to react and what to do because well the
data gif doesn't does not tells us
directly how to react uh on these
changes in the environment and there are
many scenarios which are pretty possible
there can be some
easier changes like simple calibration
or maybe retraining the model on top of
some newer data and you can perfectly do
it this in this can be even optimized
right but sometimes when you have
bigger changes in the environment we
need to perform a lot of action it can
include the labeling of new data and
selecting the specific segments of data
to label and retraining or even
rebuilding model including the batch of
new experiments and feature engineering
well this is possible and sometimes we
need to invest time in it if you need to
keep the model's quality higher
sometimes uh if for example we detect a
drift and we figure out that we need to
replay in our model but we do not have
enough data to
rebuild new model we can search for
another solution like maybe switch to
some alternative process let's say rule
based statistical based or manual and
maybe this will cover um and serve as a
fallback for our model
you can even change some business logic
or perform some model post processing
actions
maybe you can have higher decision
threshold maybe you can exclude some
specific segments or send some objects
to the manual review this can also help
to keep the quality of our servers high
so last thing that i want to add there
is
creating the monitoring schema is the
pretty creative task by itself because
we need to
accumulate to be able to take into
account the scenario of model usage and
make sure that our monitoring schema is
relevant for the specific scenario so
the monitoring should be designed with
respect to the use case and the expected
risks
in most cases the model's performance is
enough so to make sure that our models
are working we need to calculate model
years and some business or product
metrics in most cases that's good enough
but sometimes if you have some specific
cases like delayed feedback or volatile
target function it make sure to set up
an early monitoring and data gift can be
a perfect solution there
to detect model issues earlier we can
look at changes in the input feature
distributions we can analyze the model
outputs and make sure that it's not
changed and you can look for
outliers
it makes sense sometimes to catch
individual errors and to look for
outlier shares and measure the changes
there
it evidently we have some very nice
reports that cover first two things
mainly data drift and models output gift
it's completely open source so we are
happy to
i see you in our github
checking out our reports and dashboards
and the integrations with grafana for
example to set up the complete machine
learning monitoring
for performance and data list
um i think that's all i wanted to share
with you today i'm super happy to
answer some questions and
discuss how we can set up the machine
learning monitoring for production usage
thank you so much
thank you very much emilia very
interesting talk
um
let's go for a couple of questions
now
um
[Music]
so
um
gavinta asked
what skill data
can
evidently handle
ah that's a very nice question thank you
for this
i need to say that we are pretty early
stage and for now we covered only
tabular data which means that we work
with basic tabular data and time series
as well
uh and yes we are working on text maybe
this will be the next data type type but
for now that's it
let's see
is it possible to take data drift in
image models
emily
[Music]
super nice question um
yes uh there are specific approaches to
use for um
images uh and maybe for videos but i'm
not speculating there uh so for um if
you're talking about uh computer
relations uh we can focus on
some um
yeah it will be more theoretical because
we did not
implement it in evidently but this is
still possible i believe in computer
vision it makes sense to analyze the
weights on some neurons that we have
during the training and maybe analyze
the drift there if you retain the
machine learning model
for images i believe it's uh important
to analyze the categories of images if
you have some categorization and see
whether there are some changes in the
amount of images from different
categories and there i would focus more
on the outputs drift for example if we
predict some categories for pictures we
can see whether for example the balance
of these categories has changed and
maybe it makes sense to uh perform some
manual labeling sometimes if it has
something like outlier detection to see
what new segments or what new types of
images we have so i would
spend more and invest more time on the
output drift there and outlier detection
great
simona asked if
could you please give examples of how to
run drift tests on past data
to learn from it
very nice question actually i'm a big
fan of this approach because i believe
historical data data should be used
exactly in this way so uh if we have
enough of historical data we can split
it into groups like
more recent and less recent and
decide on the window size and select the
right statistical test for example if
you assume that you have some
seasonality let's say weekly seasons
then you can move
a couple of months in the past and start
comparing your data is the weekly window
size so you can select
for example common growth neuronal test
or
anderson darling and see whether you're
able to detect drift with this test with
this window size in the past it's uh
especially um
let's say uh nice when you have some
specific moments where where you know
exactly that there were some issues so
there are gifts and in this case uh
calculating this drift on top of
historical data you can just check
whether you detect it in the moment when
you wanted to detect it and whether you
sense too much the wrong alarms and
based on this analysis you can decide on
window size on the exact statistical
test on the confidence level and things
like this so i believe the historical
data is the very nice let's say
playground to select the right
monitoring schema so i would use it to
figure out the window size to select the
right statistical test and the right
confidence level and actually you can
use for example several different
windows for example you can measure lift
piste weekly window and together i
measure lift with a monthly window it
can tell you the information in a bit
different way so you can see better
whether your data changes from week to
week and whether you have some major
trends right so uh it's also possible
and we can have
different uh windows for reproduction at
the same moment which is pretty okay and
sometimes very useful
great um there was another question over
here uh
so anatoly asked
how do you integrate in
in the life environment
oh
um in a light environment
interesting so um let's let me start
from the tool because right now
evidently is the python library it's
just python package which can be
installed it's helpful help of pip
install so it's piper package and uh it
takes the data from csv files or from
pandas data frame from python so the
integration is a pretty lightweight you
either should have your data prepared as
a csv file or as upon this data frame in
order to make evidently read it then we
can generate either interactive
dashboards
in html format or just json files and
this data can be easily integrated into
some databases or monitoring solutions
right now we have several examples
available in our github repositories so
we can check it out
we have integration with mfo there we
have the
data gift analysis um performed by
evidently and emily flow lock the result
of this analysis we have an integration
with air flow and therefore we compare
uh also drift uh detection but for the
whole data set and we um create the
reports and if the list is detected then
you create a very nice visual report
with a lot of information about what is
happening in your data set
and the last one which is more suitable
for real-time usage you have the
integration with grafana we have an
example where we created the very nice
dashboard on grafana
and there we used evidently as a backend
to calculate the drift matrix and we use
primitives to store these metrics and
graphana uses primitives as the data
source so uh as evidently creates the
json's file as an files as an output
it's fairly easy to integrate it
somewhere but we have very nice examples
and tutorials that can that you can just
reuse and maybe substitute the existing
data sets and models with your ones if
you have it and try to run it for your
data hopefully it should be
easy enough
all right i think time is over uh if
anyone has any other questions or would
like to discuss or reach out emily um
please do so through dislike or the
gallery that town um
so thank you emily again uh for you
interesting and for being part of pi
data global
2021 thank you very much
thank you so much